AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪>> WE HOPE YOU ARE HAVING
MERRY CHRISTMAS EVE.
WE HAVE LOTS OF GOODIES IN STORE
IS.
A TRIP DOWN MEMORY LANE IN
DALLAS WITH A HAUNTED HOUSE
EXPERIENCE THAT JESSE AND I AND
THE LOOKING BACK AT THE MOST FUN
MOMENTS OF THE YEAR INCLUDING A
CHRISTMAS TREAT HEADED TO A
FAMOUS TOY STORE.
OUR TEAM PUT TOGETHER SOME
INDIVIDUAL HIGHLIGHTS OF THE 5
OF US.
I WILL GO FIRST.
WATCH THIS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WHAT ABOUT KEVIN?
>> OH, THANK GOD.
THAT WAS A COMMERCIAL BREAK
FLUB.
I AM SORRY.
THE SCAR I HAVE IS WHEN I FELL
OFF THE 3 WHEELER.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> HE ASKED ME IF I WAS WEARING
HEELS BECAUSE I AM SO SHORT.
WE WERE TOLD TO WEAR FLATS.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT DANA IS
WEARING HEELS.
>> OKAY, I WILL TAKE THEM OFF.
>> SHE IS ACTUALLY SHORTER.
>> DANA CORNY JOKES.
WHAT DO YOU CALL A RUNNING
TURKEY?
WHAT DO YOU CALL A SHORT COURT
TRIAL?
I KNOW WE HAVE TO GO.
>> IT'S A GREAT CHART.
I SENT IT TO EVERYONE THIS
MORNING.
>> YOU GET LIKE 8 CHARTS FROM
DANA.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I OPENED IT.
>> WHO SEND CHARTS BEFORE 9
A.M.?
>> LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT JASPER.
JASPER'S BIRTHDAY.
>> JASPER!
>> JASPER.
>> CHASING PEOPLE AROUND WITH A
REPRESENT TILE.
>> [BLEEP].
>> HELLO DANA.
>> HI, MOM.
>> I WANTED TO TELL YOU, YOU ARE
NOT IN TROUBLE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I WILL TRY THAT.
THAT ALL HAPPENED IN ONE YEAR.
>> YOU HAD A WILD YEAR.
A LOT OF HIGHLIGHTS AND
LOWLIGHTS.
THOSE ARE NOT JOKES.
THOSE ARE RIDDLES.
>> DO YOU WANT ME TO CHANGE IT?
>> IT SHOULD BE A CORNY RIDDLE.
ARE YOU AMAZED HOW OFTEN YOU SAY
JASPER.
WE DID A JASPER INTERVENTION.
>> I CAN'T REMEMBER HOW MANY
DAYS I TOOK OFF AND HALF OF
THOSE HIGHLIGHTS WERE SOMEONE
ELSE IN THE CHAIR.
DO YOU TAKE A LOT OF VACATIONS?
>> YES, DO YOU.
>> OR EVERYONE ELSE ON THE SHOW
DOESN'T LIKE WATCHING YOU AGAIN.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE BAD.
I WOULD CALL THEM JOKES.
THEY MAKE ME LAUGH.
>> A JOKE IS DIFFERENT THAN A
RIDDLE.
>> CORNY JOKES WORKS BETTER THAN
CORNY RIDDLES.
SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR HEIGHT.
YOU WOULD MAKE A GREAT
PROFESSIONAL SNOWBOARDER OR
GYMNAST.
>> YOU ARE 5 FOOT TALL.
>> WHAT I DOCKED WITH AN EXTRA 3
INCHES OF HEIGHT.
>> WHAT CAN COULD YOU DO?
>> MY MOM WAS 4 FEET 11.
>> THEN YOU CHEAT AND SAY YOU
ARE 5 FOOT.
SHORT PEOPLE, THEY ARE LARGER
THAN LIFE.
>> I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS NEXT
ROUNDUP.
SOME ENTERTAINING STUFF.
JESSE'S HIGHLIGHTS.
>> CIVILIZATION WENT DOWNHILL
WHEN I JOINED "THE FIVE."
>> McCARTHY HAD A GREAT PIECE.
>> WE HAVE BEEN QUOTING HIM ALL
WEEK.
>> WHAT IS SO FUNNY?
>> WE SHOULD USE MORE MOTIVE
CLIPS.
IT'S LIKE YOU ARE NOT FUNNY
ENOUGH TO GET THE AUDIENCE TO
LAUGH MORE.
>> JESSE YOU ARE THE KING OF
WHAT ABOUT-ISMS.
>> HERE IS ONE.
YOU CAME TO THE RIGHT PERSON.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> AND LASTLY, STOP TALKING
ABOUT YOUR HAIR!
>> I HAVE A NEW HAIRSTYLE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> LOOKING TO THE SIDE IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> I AM CONSIDERED LIKE A METR
METRO-SEXUAL.
HOW WOULD I LOOK WITH HAIR LIKE
THAT?
THERE IT IS.
>> IT'S THE SAME.
>> MY MOTHER TOLD ME TO STOP
TALKING ABOUT MY HAIR.
I WAS BULLIED AS A CHILD.
>> YOU DESERVED IT.
>> YOU ARE SO OUT OF TOUCH.
>> JUAN IS SHOWING SIGNS OF
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
>> HE IS EXTREMELY SHORT.
>> ARE THOSE MY HIGHLIGHTS?
YOU CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY DIDN'T
SHOW YOUR JACKETS.
I LOVE YOUR JACKETS.
YOU WEAR THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
JACKETS.
>> WE WILL DO THAT NEXT TIME.
>> THE POWDER BLUE.
>> THE LIBERACE OF FOX NEWS.
>> THE BIG STAR IS THE MOM TAG.
>> WE SHOULD DO THE WHOLE SHOW
THAT.
>> AND YOUR MOM GAVE ME THE
TRUMP CLOCKDOWN CLOCK T. SPEEDED
UP.
I NEED MORE!
8 YEARS NOT 4.
>> I LOVE HAVING IS YOU HERE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A REAL TREAT.
HERE'S JUAN.
>> GUESS WHAT AND GUESS WHAT?
GUESS WHAT?
TAKE A LOOK AT MY GRANDKIDS.
ELI IS STARTING 3rd GRADE AND
THE GIRLS OFF TO 1st GRADE.
I BROUGHT PICTURES.
EXCHANGING RINGS WITH FATHER CJ.
THAT'S ME 40 YEARS AGO CUTTING
MY WEDDING CAKE.
PARTY TIME.
TIME FOR "ONE MORE THING."
THESE ARE THE DOG DAYS OF
SUMMER.
BIG BOYS CRY TOO.
I AM ALL SHOOK UP.
SATURDAY IT WAS GIRLS GONE WILD
IN D.C.
TALK ABOUT JUMPING OUT OF THE
FRYING PAN AND INTO THE FIRE.
DEMOCRATS?
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT THE ONES TO
BLAME.
>> COME ON!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> GO AHEAD.
>> COME ON, MAN!
THE LARGER POINT.
>> I AM RIGHT.
>> THAT'S ALWAYS TRUE.
>> YOU HAVE OPTIMISM SWIRL AND
THE PEACE PENDULEUM.
>> WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC
PLATFORM?
>> WE CHANGE OUR MEACHAMRY.
>> THEN THE ANSWER IS JUAN WON.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> DO I GET MORE RESPECT WINNING
THE SUPERMARKET --
>> NO, YOU GET NO RESPECT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT I FEEL LIKE?
YOUR "ONE MORE THING" INTROS ARE
LIKE WHAT THE LOCAL NEWSCASTER
DOES.
>> HERE'S ONE:
GUESS WHAT!
COME ON!
THAT'S THE WAY IT ROLLS.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> AND A FACIAL EXPRESSION.
>> YEAH.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU LEFT OUT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THIS TABLE.
I AM SITTING HERE AT THIS TABLE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S A LOT OF FUN TO SEE.
IT'S LIKE SELF-REVELATION.
>> I LOVE HOW MUCH YOU LOVE YOUR
FAMILY.
THAT'S WONDERFUL.
YOU TALK ABOUT THEM.
YOU REALLY GIVE PEOPLE A GLIMPSE
INSIDE.
THEY THINK YOU ARE THE WORST
PERSON ON THE PLANET.
THEN THEY REALIZE YOU ARE DEEPLY
CONNECTED AND THE FACT YOU
RAISED REPUBLICANS GIVES VIEWERS
HOPE.
>> HE DID ONE THING RIGHT.
>> DID THEY THINK THAT I WAS
BORN WITHOUT A FAMILY OR NEVER
HAD A FAMILY?
>> THE THING ABOUT GUESS WHAT,
THAT COULD BE ANY YEAR.
>> IT'S SPREADING.
NOW EVERYBODY IS DOING IT.
YOU HEAR IT EVERYWHERE.
>> YOU MUST WATCH A LOT OF TV.
>> I DO.
>> BECAUSE GUESS WHAT?
WE WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO GO DOWN
GREG'S MEMORY LANE.
WATCH THIS.
>> SHE CIRCLED THE EARTH IN A
GRAVY BOAT.
DANA PERINO AND SKIS IN A SUGAR
BOWL.
A PAPER CLIP IS HER TROMBONE.
I VICTIM BRET BAIER.
-- I HAVE BRET BAIER.
I AM WATCHING YOUR SPECIAL
COVERAGE.
ONE MORE THING, THE GREEN FOOD
IN THE D.C. BUREAU IS NOT GOOD!
>> HE HAS A BODYSUIT.
ME AND LOU DOBBS WILL GO TO THE
PARK.
WE USE OUR BODYWEIGHT AS
RESISTANCE TRAINING.
BORN TO BE WILD, THE LIFE AND
TIMES OF LOU DOBBS.
HIS BOOK IS DOING GREAT.
IF YOU HAVE NOT BOUGHT MY BOOK,
YOU ARE DEAD MEAT.
I HAVE A GIFT FOR EVERY ONE OF
YOU AND I FORGOT TO SIGN THEM.
YOU CAN BUY THE BOOK AND IT WILL
CHANGE YOUR LIFE.
I NEED A MIC.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I WILL NUMBER DALLAS.
I WILL BE IN FORT WORTH, TEXAS.
IT'S TIME FOR ANIMALS ARE GREAT!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THIS HAMSTER IS GREAT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT ANIMAL IS
REALLY GREAT?
>> A LITTLE DUCK.
>> ANIMALS ARE GREAT!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S INCUREIABLE.
>> YOU CAN DEFINE YOUR YEAR AS
ANIMALS ARE GREAT AND YOUR BOOK
AND LOU DOBBS.
>> WHAT ELSE DO YOU NEED?
>> SOUNDS LIKE AN IDEAL WEEKEND.
>> IF I INVENT ONE THING AND NO
ONE REMEMBERS ANYTHING ELSE,
IT'S ANIMALS ARE GREAT.
>> WHAT ABOUT BRET BAIER SAYING
CAPTAIN KANGAROO SANG IT.
>> HE SANG A DIFFERENT SONG.
HIS NAME WAS BEAR BUT DIDN'T
KNOW MUCH ABOUT ANIMALS.
>> THE LITTLE KID THAT WATCH
"THE FIVE" LOVE TO WATCH "ONE
MORE THING" AND THE ANIMALS.
>> IF YOU JUST ADD ONE LITTLE
ANIMAL THING OR ONE YELLING
THING ACTING SILLY, KIDS LIKE
IT.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN YOU WATCHED
A SHOW AS A KID AND YOU LIKED IT
BUT DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
>> GREG DOING IT FOR THE KIDS.
>> LIKE THIS SWEATER.
>> DO YOU LEAVE THAT AT THE
OFFICE?
>> IT'S BEEN SITTING ON THE
SHELF FOR 365 DAYS.
IT DOES KIND OF SMELL.
>> THAT'S AN OLD WORD FOR
TAILORING.
>> MY RELATIONSHIP TO YOU, GREG.
WHEN I GO OUT INTO THE REST OF
THE FOX WORLD, I SAY LOU, DON'T
COMPLAIN TO ME.
I DON'T CONTROL HIM.
IF I GO TO THE D.C. BUREAU, I
SAID BRET, THIS IS BETWEEN AND
YOU GREG, NOT ME!
LEAVE ME OUT OF IT.
AND DANA SAID DON'T YOU THINK HE
IS MAKING FUN OF ME?
NO, IT'S ALL IN GOOD FUN.
>> AND GOOD FUN, WATCH KENNEDY.
>> OH, NO.
>> I AM WATCHING THE FIREWORKS
WITH A BASKET OF POPCORN HERE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT LOOKS LIKE JESSE.
>> YOU WANT THE PRESIDENT TO
HAVE ANOTHER SUMMIT WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I GIVE UP.
>> I THINK I BROKE MY FOOT.
I WAS KICKING.
I HAVE A VISION OF ROBERT
MUELLER LIKE A PAINTER IN FRONT
OF A CANVASS AND SAY I AM AN
ARTIST WHEN YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN
IT'S DONE.
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD,
MIRRANDA.
>> IT'S CHARLOTTE.
>> I AM CHARLOTTE.
>> WESTERN EUROPE.
MY MOM WORKS FOR THE PHONE
COMPANY.
I TOLD HER I WAS GOING TO SPEND
THE NIGHT AT THE FRIEND'S HOUSE
BUT I WENT TO THE REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> MY MOM IS A LIFE-LONG
DEMOCRAT.
THE ONLY TIME IN MY LIFE I WAS
GROUNDED.
JESSE, IF I AM IN A BAD MOOD, I
GO TO youTUBE AND WATCHING THE
CRYING HILLARY CLINTON
SUPPORTERS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THIS IS A DRINK CALLED THE
HILLARY.
>> NICE!
>> SMASHED BLACKBERREES AND SOME
WINE BECAUSE IT HAS TO BE BITTER
AND ENOUGH TEQUILA TO BREAK THE
GLASS CEILING.
>> YOU ARE ALWAYS GOOD FOR
LAUGHS.
>> BLESS YOUR BONES.
>> DO YOU KNOW YOU ARE FUNNY?
>> THAT'S AN INSIDE JOKE.
AN ANCHOR WENT UP TO KENNEDY AND
SAID DO YOU KNOW YOU ARE FUNNY?
>> LOU DOBBS.
>> NO, IT WASN'T LOU DOBBS!
IT WASN'T LOU DOBBS.
REMEMBER THE SHOWS THAT DID
FLASH BACK EPISODES.
I HATED THAT BUT THIS IS BETTER.
>> I JUST LIKE FLASH BACKS.
>> IS THAT LITTLE CHICK OKAY?
>> IT IS DUCKLING.
YES, IT CHANGED SPECIES AND
BLOSSOMED INTO A BEAUTIFUL SWAN.
>> IS THAT WHAT THEY BECOME?
>> SURE!
YEAH.
>> I BELIEVED IT.
>> WHAT DO PEOPLE ASK ABOUT THE
MOST?
>> ABOUT JUAN.
WHY DO YOU LET JUAN GET AWAY
WITH SO MUCH.
WHEN I WAS FILLING IN FOR YOU
THE OTHER NIGHT AT THE WOMAN
AWARD CEREMONY.
>> YOU BACKED OUT OF THAT?
>> SHE WAS AT A FUNERAL.
>> NEVER MIND.
>> A YOUNG MAN SAID YOU HAVE DO
LOOK OUT FOR JUAN.
HE IS MY GUY.
I WATCH FOX AND "THE FIVE" FOR
JUAN.
THEY WANT TO KNOW --
>> YOU CAN'T DRINK ALCOHOL ON
TV.
>> YOU TELL ME NOW.
DID IT TASTE GOOD?
>> IT WAS FANTASTIC.
YOU CAN DRINK IN COMMERCIAL
BREAKING NEWS.
>> I DO!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> EXACTLY.
>> YOU AND SCOTT ADAMS.
>> THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN GREAT.
>> THE PRODUCERSED!
IT'S THE BEST OF TIMES AND THE
WORST OF TIMES.
ALWAYS THE BEST OF TIMES ON "THE
FIVE."
>> THAT WOULD BE A GOOD LEAD FOR
A BOOK.